Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Consider this problem: we have a pair of images
that are visually quite different, but have
similar semantic meanings, and we wish to
map points between them.
Now this might sound a bit weird, so bear
with me for a moment.
For instance, geese and airplanes look quite
different, but both have wings, and front,
and back regions.
The paw of a lion looks quite different from
a cat's foot, but they share the same function
and are semantically similar.
This is an AI-based technique that is able
to find these corresponding points between
our pair of images, in fact, the point pairs
you've seen so far have been found by this
AI.
The main difference between this and previous
non-learning-based techniques is that instead
of pairing up regions based on pixel color
similarities, it measures how similar they
are in terms of the neural network's internal
representation.
This makes all the difference.
So far this is pretty cool, but is that it?
Mapping points?
Well if we can map points effectively, we
can map regions as a collection of points.
This enables two killer applications.
One, this can augment already existing artistic
tools so that we can create a hybrid between
two images.
And the cool thing is that we don't even need
to have any drawing skills because we only
have to add these colored masks and the algorithm
finds and stitches together the corresponding
images.
And two, it can also perform cross-domain
image morphing.
That's an amazing term, but what does this
mean?
This means that we have our pair of images
from earlier, and we are not interested in
stitching together a new image from their
parts, but we want an animation where the
starting point is one image, the ending point
is the other, and we get a smooth and meaningful
transition between the two.
There are some really cool use-cases for this.
For example, we can start out from a cartoon
drawing, set our photo as an endpoint, and
witness this beautiful morphing between the
two.
Kind of like in style transfer, but we have
more fine-grained control over the output.
Really cool.
And note that many images inbetween are usable
as-is.
No artistic skills needed.
And of course, there is a mandatory animation
that makes a cat from a dog.
As usual, there are lots of comparisons to
other similar techniques in the paper.
This tool is going to be invaluable for, I
was about to say artists, but this doesn't
require any technical expertise, just good
taste and a little bit of imagination.
What an incredible time to be alive.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!